[Music]
you know at the key the matter of like
you know when dis research actually
translate to change in policy and I
think Excel said life is messy I would
say research is messy as well and you
know charting how research turns into
policy changes is really you know
sometimes frustrating sometimes
challenging you know and I think marine
had this or maybe Isaac's had this a
triangle of you know you needed
political support you needed to be on
the ground floor and you needed credible
research and it's rare for all those
things to line up it does happen and
there's some stories one example I give
as well but and maybe talk later on
application assistance to fill out for
financial aid some of the work that I
and others have been doing on trying to
simplify the process of getting through
the application to post-secondary seems
to have tracked it you know a lot of
attention and interest in you know
simplifying or making the transition to
post-secondary easier but there are
other examples but they're they're not
as many as as we'd like okay so I think
I've got five minutes left so I'm gonna
this is great thank you for having me
and and I'm gonna echo a lot of points
that marina made maybe a bit more on the
academic side and so I thought I'd give
you a little bit of a case study in
trying to work with pathways to
education to try to do some research
many of you know
that this organization was a grassroots
organization that started in while the
program is implemented in 2001 at Regent
Park which is not too far from here it's
the largest housing project in in the
country and the purpose was to try to
break this cycle of poverty and was
motivated by it was started at the
Community Health Organization they
managed to raise some money from the
Trillium Foundation and had the luxury
to really think about introducing you
know very integrated complete expensive
program to try to see if they could help
disadvantaged youth especially through
high school so very briefly the program
is it starts for people entering grade 9
and they get a very integrated set of
programs anyone who lives in Regent Park
and and now other projects entering
grade 9 is eligible for the program it's
voluntary they have to sign a form to
commit to the program the parents sign a
form as well and then if they do that
they get assigned a student support
worker that meets with them about every
two weeks and helps guide them
throughout their high school time in
high school and then they also get
tutoring up to four nights a week and
tutoring is supposed to be mandatory up
to two times a week on top of that
there's a whole set of social support
there's monthly or bimonthly group
activities including issues around
stress management or just going to a
sporting event and then there's
financial support in terms of free
public transportation and also
post-secondary scholarship that's four
thousand so there's very integrated
approach you probably know about
pathways because of this report that
came out in 2007 by the Boston
Consulting Group and at the very bottom
here they have that the before pathways
from Regent Park the dropout rate was 56
percent a high school dropout rate after
pathways it was ten percent for eighty
percent reduction
you know David Pico who had a study was
on the consulting firm he was also on
the pathways board of directors he said
you know this is the highest rate of
turn that we've ever seen now this this
change is is off the charts and it's you
know we don't see these kind of impacts
in education programs almost anywhere
and so to kind of have that kind of
impact and say this is what pathway is
doing it's certainly us for further
research or anyone seeing this you know
doing research and education gets really
excited but also you know a naturally
skeptical wanting to kind of understand
whether this is real if it is real how
is it happening and so possiblys got a
lot of attention from this and they
managed to you know expand it and and
national from that but it this kind of
program and the research related to
trying to evaluate shouldn't stop there
and it is worthwhile to try to have
others try to look at the program from a
different perspective maybe a different
methodology and it is healthy to have a
dialogue and discussion on whether these
this is the truth and and I think that's
where academics can come and help but
also there's some tension that sometimes
comes with that because from the
organization's point of view this
results is you know is is enough to you
know it's in the direction that they
want to see
this is slight a similar to Marines in
terms of like well what's in it for
organizations to kind of have more
academics play you know of role in
trying to evaluate the program I think
she said there's some incentives to be
some impression that if the research has
only done internally
there's feathering one's own nest right
and one advantage if you know for to
have additional multiple investigations
of the program is you can have arm's
length interest for looking at it this
brings credibility also brings
alternative perspectives and we're cheap
too sometimes we're more interested in
you know we're happy to kind of
participate and look at it for the sake
of science and and you know you know we
don't you don't have to pay us
consulting fees sometimes we have you
know emphasis on causal inference trying
to understand what is the what is the
counterfactual what's the comparison
group and trying to understand and
evaluate the program and we might be
able to have bring more time to an
investigation often the organization's
themselves are just are very busy
operating the program and the capacity
to do detailed research is limited so we
can do that and the last one I don't
know if you can see now here is just one
more funders want it funders want to see
sort of some external type of evaluation
and and so that's another reason of
course the other reason not to want this
is that well we might find results that
you know disappoint the organization and
there's very little often incentive for
an organization to welcome researches in
when they have you know a strong support
for the program already and also you
know it's important as an academic to be
able to state what you think the
conclusions of your own research are and
as
to have a dialogue with the organization
prior you know talking about the
research but you know no academic wants
to be in situation to have you know a
filter from the organization what you're
able to say and so it's important to
have a non filtered presentation the
results that can also stand up to
scrutiny and sometimes the
organization's are nervous about that
sometimes in order to do the research
the operations may Knight may actually
need to be changed or flexible in order
to accommodate evaluation on and this is
often easier said and done you know
there's different methodologies it was
discussed earlier that sometimes there's
a methodology hierarchy and that exists
for a reason you know often if you're
able to set up a randomized control
trial you have a credible comparison
group more credible than anything else
you can produce and at least on an
aggregate level in in in in very
specific context you're able to tell
what would have happened in the absence
of treatment I mean the accident program
sometimes these things can be set up
easier than others and and sometimes
they're not easily set up but trying to
accommodate the research to set up a
comparison group is extremely useful and
we learn a lot from it but often it
might require change we still need the
qualitative research as well but to
really understand you know the bigger
picture
it there helps a lot to have a credible
comparison group one small example is
the Big Brothers Big Sisters study that
they had a long line up but people
wanted to be a big brother big sister
and they took advantage of that lineup
and rather than going in order they took
a series of people and they said would
you be okay with selecting at random
from the lineup who gets a bigger sister
big brother
quicker and from that they were able to
assess them program so in the pathways
example it took me three years to sort
of establish the relationship to kind of
say I didn't have an Indy ology I just I
really wanted to know whether this was
real and and wanted to see whether this
program was going and you know it took a
long time because there was reluctance
and concern you almost have nowhere to
go but down in terms of once you have a
56% to 10% result and you know to be
honest it helped that most of my
analysis it took a while to realize this
could come from data from outside
pathways and I think from not and also
just a lot of goodwill and sitting down
with them you know establish these
relationships so very quickly you know
it actually does turn out that pathways
has a very high participation rate so
within two years of the program these
red bars show that in Regent Park
participation goes up above 80 percent
and and of all the people who could be
participating in pathways you've got you
know eighty five ninety percent of
people volunteering for the program
which is a very high take up and the
other lines are for the other sites
Lawrence Heights and and Rexdale that
were introduced in 2007 also almost
immediately participation is really high
and so the way that this study was set
up you know we can't randomize in
pathways but we have is people from
other housing projects and this shows
the enrolment rate in post-secondary
after five years since starting grade
nine and you should show you for those
who start in grade nine starting in 2000
or 2001 all the way up to 2009 what the
post-secondary enrollment rates are over
over time so you see them edging up
around 30 percent and so that orange dot
is what it was for Regent Park for 2000
before pathways wasn't introduced and so
without the absence of the program the
comparison group is to sort of follow
this line and say that's probably what
would have happened or that's our best
guess of what would happen so when you
actually go to the data I look at Regent
Park you actually do see a fairly
substantial rise in post-secondary woman
in fact if you normalize this if you
kinda
put these back together the gap that
opens up almost exactly the time that
path was introduced was a very large
rise and and so it turns out with with
the data that I was obtained that my
best guess of this impact for region
Park was now almost a 19 percentage
point increase in pole second point
which is also off the charge was very
encouraging still when you go look at
the other sites that were introduced in
2007 instead of this 19 percentage point
you have a much lower estimated impact
at 3.5 percentage point increase in
enrollment although if you focus on just
college you get a six point five
percentage point increase in community
college enrollment which is still
generally impressive but if you you know
you go back and you report these results
to pathways and others generally the
reactions mix there's sort of some
disappointment that I wasn't able to
show the 56% you know this is this giant
increase but from that work there's
ongoing quality to work to try to
understand what's going the mechanisms
that's going on there and that's I'm not
and so I've had to team up with some
people doing qualitative work to try to
get down and I have to say also there's
it from academic to really get on the
ground floor to work with these people
in size it is a pleasure it is because
you get some idea of all the effort and
and the messiness going on the ground
floor that needs to be appreciated that
you don't when you're doing you know
when you're just showing those figures
so I think the combination of the
research is important and from that you
learn stuff like the attendance for the
tutoring and meaning the coaches is
actually not that high or not as high as
they would say it is from the you know
the rules of the program so one of the
things that we're trying to explore now
is to try to ways fine what find ways to
increase attendance to see within the
program whether that actually would made
improve so it's not just about the
evaluation program as a whole but how
things could be improved eternally so
one thing is we're looking at is texting
to provide more salient reminders
sending messages on the day that
tutoring could be occurring to encourage
participation and a you know a big
advantage of the texting is that it's
cheap and you can randomize who you text
to and so we have a comparison group to
explore how participation changes and
whether through increased participation
increase participation get more people
to the tutoring and the coaching so I
know I'm at a time so let me just kind
of summarize that there is you know
there's a need to work together it often
requires sort of respectful open-minded
relations and so as an academic you have
to realize that you know you can't just
trounce it and say you're doing it all
wrong you have to do it you have to
really understand where they're coming
from but also you know be really open
minded and also encourage scrutiny
scrutiny is healthy trying to understand
the truth what works to make things
better because we are you know related
in trying to improve well-being
especially for some of these
disadvantaged families and I think
there's lots of room to try to do that
together
[Applause]
to a few questions but I first of all
want to say that was fascinating and I
really want to acknowledge you for
sticking with it for three years and
generating that enough goodwill because
I can imagine how important that was to
be able to offer what sounds like has
been very useful data for program
improvement and deepening and enhancing
the outcomes that they're able to
generate and I'm sure that wasn't easy
and lots of I think richness in this
question and I think as you framed it
about accepting the negative data being
willing to sort of embrace potentially
things that aren't working in the spirit
of being able to make sure you're
allocating those resources in a way that
could have more impact in this idea of
ongoing research and implementing
diverse methodologies I think because I
think a lot of a lot of important value
there just to pull out a few things so
let me turn it over to you who's got any
questions for Philip yeah okay any any
new hands
hi I'm Bill with things Stephens
Community House I'm doing some youth
research as well right now so I'm very
interesting in your thoughts about text
messaging and I know you were hurrying
at the end like text messaging is a good
way to send information to youth how are
you finding it a good way to collect
information from youth there are there
are different possibilities with text
you know Maureen brought up behavioral
insights there's a lot of and it was
great to hear that people are thinking
about you know behavioral economics on
this stuff there's a lot of interesting
theories behind why texting both pushing
out messages and kind of receiving
messages might be very helpful pushing
out is the issues around you know just
providing salient reminders at the time
that you might take action often leads
to a higher likelihood of actually doing
that action but receiving messages also
really opens up a line of communication
that we've never really had before it's
a really cheap way of of having students
or individuals feel that they can reach
out with someone at any time during the
day at a at a time when something pops
up in their head where they don't have
to sort of then set up a schedule or
meeting and so a one project to have
right now is with first-year
undergraduates where when we say send
messages they can respond to us and
often the message themselves when you
send something is a reminder that they
can send a message back and that's when
we get the most communication and you
know this research is ongoing but the
sense is that the the the students who
do respond really appreciate the line of
communication of being able to talk to
you know a faculty member at nine
o'clock at night it goes to me sometimes
or you know a graduate student or
someone to some you know that that there
doesn't need to be a pause between the
idea that some comes to head and a need
to communicate so I think texting is a
new technology that we're only now
becoming aware that it might be an
effective
addition to some of the programs the way
that were implementing the programs
thanks for that question and you're
cheap so I wanted to explore that a
little bit more for lots of different
reasons but you're cheap sometimes but
not always when we have tenders going
out for different research projects for
example if we get bids from academic
teams we often have to they have to
submit their bids with these large
management fees from the institutions
but what does that what are the
different options for relationships for
community organizations with academics
to do the work the kind of work you're
doing on program improvement the kind of
work we might need on other kinds of
research that we might want to be doing
and how do we go how do we all get to
know about the different routes into
building those relationships and taking
advantage of the cheapness sometimes
yeah sure this question I mean the path
waste is an example where you know this
project was done on on no money you know
that the money that for doing the
qualitative study is picking up but the
the data was a made available part from
pathways part from TSP for free and you
know the interest in in sort of a young
academic wanting to understand a project
that seems quite attractive the interest
or incentive for me was to understand
this program a bit better and have the
opportunity to share results the
research so you know often the chance to
publish but published also means
disseminate and discuss and share ideas
the chance to do that is is often more
valuable than then you know be paid
sometimes the research involves you know
hi I'm research assistants and other
things but that's part of what we do and
we raise money for that so
I've often thought that that sometimes
when these calls for proposals for
research it you know it's possible to
direct attention or tried to find
academics who are generally interested
in this area that might be interested in
you know working with datasets that they
would not have normally accessed through
through these kind of partners and and
and be interested the one thing I would
say is as long as it helps a lot if
there's a long time period between you
know putting together a proposal so
often you will get these requests saying
there's a lot of money available if you
submit a proposal in two weeks and it's
just not enough time to drop everything
and kind of really think about that so
maybe there's a trade-off but I my
suspicion is that there is more
possibilities in bringing on academics
that are willing or more interested in
research then you know then getting paid
to as long as they had more you know
space to fit it in time to build the
relationships between the academic and
the community organization and partners
but it's similar we often get requests
and I know many of the agencies get
requests to be part of different shirker
other other tri-council grant
applications three days before the
application is due and that to me is
kind of the similar the other side of
that too and how we how we better build
some understanding on the need for
having lead up time and time to build
relationships to learn to work together
and take advantage of both the
opportunities that we offer each other
so I really appreciate your comments
ville
hi I'm Diane Dyson from what green and
really followed your research a long
time so really glad to hear you speak to
this and and you're speaking about
pathways education which is one of my
longtime areas of interest as well
looking like you how do we improve the
outcomes for young people in education
and so I have all sorts of
methodological questions that I wanted
to sort of get into with you but I think
for the use of the room what might be
more interesting is that one of the
shifts that happened in pathways to
education is after it moved out of
Regent Park and it moved into other
neighborhoods in across Canada it it was
able to do that because it had the
external validity of a boston consulting
evaluation that said this is the return
on dollar was something like 14 or 18
dollars quite an incredible number when
you look at other SRO eyes and so they
were able to do that and then when they
moved into the other places you've note
you've noted and shown us today that the
their outcomes were not as good I'm
wondering if that was then perhaps that
the burden is on us as as community
groups should that happen to us that we
need to make sure that we've got the
inside the program evaluation knowing
well enough so we know whether text
messages work whether we know whether
the counseling or the attendance work
those sorts of things that that we have
to make sure that we've paid enough
attention to the internal processes so
that there's some fidelity when we go to
other when we try to scale up our
programs yeah it's a really good point
it's hard to scale up and replicate what
seems to be working there's a little bit
of um sort of
skyla bias where you you find the study
that or you know some some initial
program looks like it's working
amazingly well and then you know there
could be a lot of luck involved in that
or a particular champion behind the
program that's really hard to pinpoint
or get a finger on what's driving that
and so when you expand it it is you know
more often than not that when you when
you look at the evaluation of the
expansion projects they're not as you
know as striking but I do think you know
an another reason could be that the
initial results were not as you know
there's some noise around your estimates
on the impact of the program maybe it
wasn't as effective begin with but I was
thinking you know it is worth noting
that pathways you know is a promising
program it looks like it has a lot of
ingredients and would not have expanded
were it not for that study right and it
were it not for them you know problems
aside problem the the program would not
have you know probably taken up beyond
Regent Park if it was just some academic
coming up with a publish academic paper
with it with just my report I doubt it
would have the same kind of impact so it
is sort of important that that they had
that report that came out at the same
time but I agree with you that that
trying to understand the mechanisms both
at Regent Park any expansion size to be
open to constant change in tweaking is
healthy to constantly try to improve on
it
and it sounds like one around scaling in
general around this this tension between
fidelity to a model versus adaptation to
a new context or environment that I
think was in pathways case sounds like
an important consideration okay we were
gonna take a break right about now
and I've sure changed some of the
questions at this point let's let's open
up to it to if we have any last question
did you have one okay if we have any
last question and then we'll break a
move to the to the breakouts any final
yeah please
well I I don't really have a question
but I wanted to to say that sitting as
the in a community-based organization
and admire the fact that other
organizations have been able to create
opportunities to do research one of the
things that I find really difficult
about it is that we kind of have to
piggyback on existing projects cuz there
are no resources so when you talk about
engagement and you were talking before
about engaging with the academics and
the community members before and so on
I'm sitting here thinking okay when am I
gonna get the time and who in my
organization can I say okay stop doing
what you're doing the thing you were
talking about units and you know we have
numbers to meet we have those kinds of
things to me that's right and and so the
reality of being able to do this is very
very difficult from where we sit now I
think it's really important because the
credibility factor is not only in the
credibility of the research and the
outcomes but it is really being able to
demonstrate as community organizations
that we are doing something that is
impactful that is meaningful that is
important and that is based on evidence
and based on you know and we have very
good support from from people in the
academic community wherever we we need
that credit
on our level to keep doing our work so
it's uh it's just striking me as a whole
other like we could open the warden
woods research arm in order to support
all of the the issues and types of
things that we're dealing with as a
multi service organization so it's
necessary we're trying but I'm just
overwhelmed with how we're gonna do it
off the side of our desks with
everything else lots of nodding heads
there were lots of nodding heads did I
comment yes yes and the good news is is
we have some funders in the room to hear
that but it's it sounds like it's a
bigger problem question yeah you want to
respond to that Phil just one thought
because like as a quick and dirty way to
maybe get up and running I mean there
might there there are lots of better
ways to do this but just letting
researchers at universities in
interested in community work or
qualitative work that have done you know
have similar interests letting them know
that you're interested in having you
know your your organization your program
evaluated or looked at might spark
interest and then getting involved
without taking up a lot of your time
like just saying I'm open to you coming
in and looking at our data and and
giving you access to speaking with
people that's often really attractive
for you know especially young academics
looking for new ideas and topic said
that would not otherwise be available to
them that might be a quick thing to do
okay well let's do let's do one last one
and we'll still give you your break and
we'll just have a little less time for
discussion at the Taylan
thanks John Kerry said I'm an assistant
family support services but I'm gonna
talk mostly on my child development
years Child Development Institute I
think the first question I'm not looking
for answers right now is why do we want
to do the research because I've heard
many different reasons I think we owe to
our clients to show that what we're
doing is effective second thing is if we
incorporate the research into what we're
already doing helps deal with the issue
of adding on to so somehow it's finding
that partnership to do that and we're
starting to get involved in a study with
violence against women and it just
happens to stars a line I know what you
want to call it but there's someone that
came to us and said we're interested in
exploring this issue and we said well we
have the women that can answer some of
your questions to start in a qualitative
note so if it's incorporated there's
something that you're already doing I
would see that it's a lot easier process
rather than trying to make it work
thanks okay I think both both really
important points and the why question I
do encourage you in your groups to spend
some time talking about because I think
we've heard that there's different why's
for the researchers for the
organizations for funders how how can
you increasingly generate that kind of
alignment around the whys which sounds
like is where some of the the real value
is going to come or at least at least
possibility okay so I've got some
instructions for the breakout
[Music]
you
[Music]